turtles
so
so
so
huh
he's done
uh
so
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
[Applause]
thank you very much please
and thank you all for being here as we
take historic action
to deliver a future of safety and
security for americans
of every race religion color
and creed we're joined today by law
enforcement professionals and community
leaders
though we may all come from different
places and different backgrounds
we're united by our desire to ensure
peace and dignity
and equality for all americans i've just
concluded a meeting with
incredible families just incredible
families that have been through
so much the families of ahmad arbury
botham john antoine rose
jemele roberson
adiana jefferson michael dean
darius tarver cameron lamb
and everett palmer
these are incredible people incredible
people
and it's so sad
many of these families lost their loved
ones in
deadly interactions with police
to all of the hurting families i want
you to know that
all americans mourn by your side
your loved ones will not have died in
vain
we are one nation we grieve together
and we heal together i can never imagine
your pain or the depth of your anguish
but i can promise
to fight for justice for all of our
people
and i gave a commitment to all of those
families today with
senator tim scott attorney general bill
barr
we are going to pursue
what we said we will be pursuing it and
we will be pursuing it strongly tim
right okay
i want to recognize attorney general
bill barr who's spent
so much time on on this and other
matters
like this bill thank you very much for
being here along with
great job you're doing
along with senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell
and tim scott and they're going to be
working on a senate bill also that can
go hand in hand with this
and also representatives kelly armstrong
louis gomert jim jordan
guy rest in charler and pete stauber
and thanks also to florida attorney
general ashley moody
the president of the fraternal order of
police
patios president of the international
association of chiefs of police
stephen cass stevens and many other law
enforcement leaders who are going to be
joining me at the signing
today is about pursuing common sense and
fighting
fighting for a cause like we seldom get
the chance to fight for
we have to find common ground
but i strongly oppose the radical and
dangerous efforts to defend dismantle
and dissolve our police departments
especially now when we've achieved the
lowest recorded crime rates in recent
history
americans know the truth without police
there is chaos without law there is
anarchy and without safety there is
catastrophe we need leaders at every
level of government who have
the moral clarity to state these obvious
facts
americans believe we must support the
brave men and women in blue
who police our streets and keep us safe
americans also believe we must improve
accountability
increase transparency and invest more
resources in police training recruiting
and community
engagement reducing crime and raising
standards are not
opposite goals they are not mutually
exclusive
they work together they all work
together
that is why today i'm signing an
executive order encouraging police
departments nationwide to adopt
the highest professional standards to
serve their communities
these standards will be as high and as
strong
as there is on earth the vast majority
of police officers
are selfless and courageous public
servants
they are great men and women
when others run away from danger police
run straight into harm's way
often putting their lives at stake to
protect someone
who they don't know or never even met
great danger police officers
run straight toward
this incredible harm
take the world trade center they ran
straight
into the twin towers of 9 11.
many of them never returned never
returned
vast numbers of new york's finest
never returned last year i presented the
medal of valor to six heroic police
officers who ended a
murderous rampage so professionally
in dayton ohio hundreds of people
would have been killed surely without
them
we ask our police to put on the uniform
and risk their lives for us every day
the least we deserve and the least we
can do
because they deserve it so much
they have to get our gratitude and
we have to give them great respect for
what they do for the
job is one of the most dangerous jobs on
earth
one of the most difficult jobs on earth
last year alone 89 law enforcement
officers were killed in the line of duty
in recent days two members of law
enforcement
were killed amid riots and looting and
hundreds of
police officers were injured just
recently
one officer was shot in the head and is
now laying in a hospital
almost totally paralyzed despite our
very good record on crime
law and order must be further restored
nationwide
and your federal government is ready
willing and able
to help as we did in
minneapolis after we got out of control
for four days
we sent in representatives commonly
known as the national guard and it was
all
put down very quickly we're willing to
help we're willing to help in seattle
we're willing to help anywhere you want
and we'll be there very quickly
it won't take long there will be no more
looting or arson and the penalty will
be very gray for those who get caught
violence and destruction will not be
tolerated we cannot do that the looters
have no cause that they're fighting for
just trouble every day police officers
make great sacrifices to keep our
communities secure and safe
in 2018 our police arrested nearly 12
000 people for murder 25
000 people for rape and nearly 1.5
million
for assault very dangerous criminals
in many cases local law enforcement is
underfunded
understaffed and under support
47 percent of all murders in chicago and
68 percent of all murders in baltimore
went without arrests last year
americans want law and order they demand
law and order
they may not say it they may not be
talking about
it but that's what they want some of
them don't even know that's what they
want but that's what they want
and they understand that when you remove
the police
you hurt those who have the least
the most nobody needs a strong
trustworthy police force more than those
who
live in distressed areas and nobody is
more opposed to the small number of
bad police officers and you have them
they're
very tiny i use the word tiny
it's a very small percentage but you
have them
but nobody wants to get rid of them more
than the
overwhelming number of really good and
great police officers
some of them are standing with me and
with me in the audience today and i
appreciate you being here
thank you thank you great job
what's needed now is not more stoking of
fear and division
we need to bring law enforcement and
communities closer together
not to drive them apart under the
executive order i'm signing today we
will prioritize federal grants from the
department of justice
to police departments that seek
independent
credentialing certifying that they meet
high standards
and in fact in certain cases the highest
standard
that's where they do the best on the use
of force
and de-escalation training for example
many believe that proper training might
have
prevented the tragic deaths of antoine
rose
and both of them jean
as part of this new credentialing
process
chokeholds will be banned except if an
officer's life
is at risk and i will say we've dealt
with all of the various departments
and everybody said it's time
we have to do it additionally we're
looking at
new advanced and powerful less lethal
weapons to help prevent deadly
interactions new devices are being
developed all the time and we're looking
at the best of them
and cost is no object no object
under this executive order departments
will also need a share
of information about credible abuses
so that officers with significant issues
do not simply move from one police
department to the next that's a problem
and the heads of our police department
said whatever you can do about that
please let us know we're letting you
know
we're doing a lot about it in addition
my order will direct
federal funding to support offices in
dealing with homeless individuals
and those who have mental illness and
substance abuse
problems we will provide more resources
for
co-responders such as social workers who
can
help officers manage these complex
encounters
and this is what they've studied and
worked on all their lives
they understand how to do it we're going
to get the best of them put in our
police departments and working with our
police
we will have reform without undermining
our many
great and extremely talented law
enforcement
officers president obama and vice
president biden never even tried to fix
this
during their eight year period the
reason they didn't try is because
they had no idea how to do it and it is
a complex situation
beyond the steps we are taking today i
am committed
to working with congress on additional
measures
congress has started already and they'll
be having bills coming out of the senate
and possibly out of the house and
hopefully they'll all get together and
they'll come up with
a solution that goes even beyond what
we're signing today but this is a big
big step a step that hasn't been taken
before
but in order to make real progress on
public safety
we have to break old patterns of failure
many of the same politicians now
presenting themselves as the solution
are the same ones who have failed for
decades on schools
jobs justice and crime
they are all often
unfortunately the same politicians
running the cities and states
where help is most needed
it's an attitude and it's not working
today's action is a big part of the
solution to restoring renewing and
rebuilding our communities
for the last three and a half years my
administration has been
focused on creating opportunity
fighting for equal justice and truly
delivering results nobody has ever
delivered results like we've delivered
nobody's come close
and we worked with some great people we
worked with fantastic people to get it
done
we enacted landmark criminal
justice reform something that nobody
else could get done
they tried and they couldn't even come
close so we got it done and we got it
done
powerfully and people appreciated it
but it's something that with all the
work and all the talk for so many years
criminal justice reform nobody else
could get done
we secured permanent and record funding
for hbcus
that's historically black colleges and
universities
numbers that they never thought were
possible
and long-term financing because they
would come back to the white house after
my third year i said
why are you here again great people
about 42 people
the heads of black
colleges on universities great people
they do such an incredible job and i'd
see them after the third year i say why
are you doing this
we need money again i said don't we set
it so you have like a 10-year program a
five-year program
no sir for years and years we've had to
come back
every single year i said well the only
bad thing about what i'm going to do
is i'm going to give you long-term
financing and i'm going to up the amount
but i won't get to see you anymore so
that's the bad part
but you can focus on education now
instead of worrying about
dealing with us in washington so we did
that
for the historically black colleges
and universities i'm very proud of it
they're incredible they're incredible
people
got to know a lot of the heads of those
colleges they do an unbelievable job
and don't get the kind of notoriety that
they should have
we expanded affordable options for
better health care
we created opportunity zones with
senator tim scott
brought it to me we didn't know if we
could get it past him right
but we got it passed and i think it's
probably one of the great things that
we've done
in this administration tens of thousands
of jobs billions and billions of dollars
being brought into areas and
neighborhoods that would never
ever ever be
taken care of monetarily areas that
didn't have 10 cents put them
in them for years and decades and now
people are investing
thriving in the jobs they've come back
we achieved the lowest black hispanic
and asian unemployment rates
in american history and we will do it
again
we'll do it again we're fighting for
school choice
which really is the civil rights of
all time in this country frankly school
choice is the civil rights
statement of the year of the decade and
probably beyond
because all children have to have access
to quality education
a child's zip code in america should
never determine their future and that's
what was happening
so we're very very strong on school
choice and i hope everybody remembers
that
and it's happening it's already happened
but it's happening we have tremendous
opposition from
people that know they shouldn't be
opposing it
choice all children deserve equal
opportunity because
we are all made equal by god so
true a great jobs market and thriving
economy is probably the best thing that
we
can do to help the black
hispanic asian communities
we saw that just recently prior to the
virus
that came in from china just a few
months ago
what a horrible thing it was all over
the world 188 countries now
and i just want to say we've done
incredibly well we're doing
well things are happening that nobody
can even
believe our country is opening up and
it's opening up
rapidly we had the best unemployment and
employment we had best unemployment
and employment numbers think of that in
the history of our country
we're up to almost 160 million people
working
there was never anything even close
and that's for almost every group
including black
hispanic asian women
young people old people
young people without a high school
diploma
every group everybody was thrilled
everybody had
just about high-paying jobs
our country was never in a better
position and we were planning on massive
growth that was happening it was already
there
including big salary increases which
were already taking place
for the last two and a half years big
big increases record increases nobody's
seen
anything like it and then we got hit by
the virus
along with the rest of the world and now
i'm building it up again
here we go again but i'm building it up
again
and it's moving fast and it will be
even better than before because we also
learned
it will be better than before jobs are
rapidly coming back
and retail sales that were just
announced two hours ago
just a little while ago they're up a
staggering 17.7 percent
the projection was anywhere from six to
eight percent
we're up 17.7
and what does that mean the stock market
went through the roof these good numbers
they drove it up to a level that
we're almost at the same level hard to
believe we're getting very close to the
level we were
before the pandemic and before
all of the things that you've seen
happen happened
that's a great thing because ultimately
it's about jobs it's about
the government can never do anything
like a great job for a person where they
look forward to getting up in the
morning and going to work and getting a
much bigger check
than they could ever get otherwise today
and over the last 60 days we've had one
of the biggest
stock market increases in the history of
the stock markets
and two weeks ago the 50-day increase
was the single biggest unless my formula
is tampered with
we will soon be in a stronger position
than we were
before the plague came in from china
when the numbers reached the point that
i know they will there will again be
a great unity and a great spirit in our
country
people will have that job back that they
might have lost
they'll be making even more money than
they did before
we have some brilliant people working
with me and
we put it together we did it once and
we're very easily doing it again we're
way ahead of schedule
you'll see that you'll see the third
quarter numbers will be very good
you'll see fourth quarter will be really
good and you'll see next year will be
one of the best
economic years this country has ever had
and it's all happening very quickly way
ahead of schedule and i think you'll see
that people can't even believe what
they're looking at
but on top of all of that before the end
of the year i predict
we will have a very successful vaccine
therapeutic and cure with making
tremendous progress i deal with these
incredible scientists doctors very very
closely
a great respect for their minds and
they have come up with things and
they've come up with
many other cures and therapeutics over
the years these are the people the best
the smartest the most brilliant anywhere
and they've come up with the aids
vaccine they've come up with
or the aids and as you know there's
various things and now various companies
are
involved but the therapeutic for aids
aids was a death sentence and now people
live a life with a pill
it's an incredible thing the ebola
vaccine
and others these are the people that
have done it
or these are the people that have been
around it and they're all competing it's
an
incredible thing all of these brilliant
firms
labs companies are competing and i will
tell you we're very far advanced we've
already started
tests and trials so
i think we're going to have a very very
good answer to that very very soon
i always say even without it it goes
away
but if we had the vaccine and we will if
we had therapeutic
or cure one thing sort of blends into
the other
it will be a fantastic day and i think
that's going to happen
and it's going to happen very soon
americans can achieve anything
when we work together as one national
family to go forward we must seek
cooperation not confrontation
we must build upon our heritage not tear
it down
and we must cherish the principles of
america's
founding as we strive to deliver safe
beautiful elegant
justice and liberty for all
i'd like now to invite our great friends
because they are our great friends from
law enforcement
the officers representing their groups
to come up as i sign a very important
executive order
and we're asking mitch and tim and
all of the people that are here from
congress to go back
and see if they can get something done i
see
louie and jim jim jordan
we'll all hear a lot of our
representatives from congress and the
senate
if they can go back and add to what
we're signing today it'll be
it'll be a big moment it'll be a big
moment but this is a tremendous step
this is a step that
could have been taken years ago but
people chose not to do that
and that was in my opinion a big mistake
could have solved
a lot of the problems that we have now
so if i could
law enforcement if you could come
forward we've had the please come up
we've had the endorsement of the federal
law enforcement officers association
the fraternal order of police
international association
of chiefs of police international union
of police associations
major county sheriffs of america
association
national association of police
organizations
national district attorneys association
national sheriff's association sergeants
benevolent association and many others
they've worked on this with me and my
team
have been fantastic i want to thank my
team what a team it is
and we've taken very much into mind what
they are saying because
these are the people that keep us safe
and they've done an incredible job
thank you all very much
[Applause]
um
thank you very much
thank you very much thank you
is
it's
award season looks like it's going to be
a lot
longer you know usually we would come
back from
new year's eve and it would be the
golden globes the you know
few days later now it looks like
probably the golden globes